even in this day and age when filmmakers
can create entire worlds with CGI
there's nothing quite like a practical
good old-fashioned stunt talented stunt
performers risk their lives to get the
shots that often wind up being the
highlight of the entire movie while
correctly executing a stunt writes a
fine line between success and disaster
stunt performers don't always pull off
the moment exactly as planned
nevertheless the cameras are rolling and
sometimes the footage captured is so
exciting that filmmakers simply have to
keep it in the final cut or the stunt
ended in actual pain and misery so more
takes weren't possible here are some
really scary movie moments where the
fear and danger were real die hard part
of the charm of die hard and what makes
it such a classic is its premise John
McClane is a regular cop rising to the
occasion to thwart a massive terrorist
plot in real life Bruce Willis was also
basically a regular guy not yet an
action movie stud best known as the star
of the romantic comedy TV series
moonlighting
thanks to diehards action-packed set
pieces stuntmen had to shoulder a lot of
the work but things didn't always go as
planned one such moment happened during
the scene where McClane leaps across an
elevator shaft Willis's stunt double was
supposed to grab on to event but his
hand slipped and he kept falling down
the shaft
the editor decided to keep that shot in
the film and it works in all kinds of
ways it makes the viewer jump a little
but it also speaks to McClane's
character he's just a normal guy
screwing up a little when he's trying to
save the day
[Music]
Back to the Future Part 2 in one of the
most crowd pleasing scenes and back to
the future part two for members of
Griff's gang chase Marty on hoverboards
and end up crashing through the glass
front of the famous hill valley
courthouse
as the stunt was planned all four stunt
performers were going to be outfitted in
harnesses and suspended from a crane
which would provide enough momentum to
send them crashing through the glass
windows then a crew member was supposed
to press a button on a remote-control
sending them descending to the safety of
airbags below the cameras rolled and the
stunt performers flew through the air
but stunt woman Cheryl wheelers rig
didn't work correctly she flew off
course and instead of bursting through a
candy glass window she had a pillar on
the outside of the building adding
injury to injury the crew member then
remotely released her sending her
crashing 25 feet onto concrete wheeler
was severely injured and sued the studio
but nevertheless the accident footage is
in the film when the game crashes
through the glass windows wheeler is
visible falling onto the sidewalk first
blood the action and first blood the
first in Sylvester Stallone's Rambo
franchise is so raw and visceral that
it's sometimes difficult to watch
Stallone plays a Vietnam vet who gets
caught in a war with a small-town Police
Department I didn't come here to rescue
Rambo from you I came here to rescue you
from him one scene in particular looks
like it must have been painful for
Stallone to shoot and that's because it
was while on the run from the military
officers charged with capturing and
quelling him
Rambo jumps off a cliff and falls
through some trees coming up hard
against some branches
[Music]
Stallone performed one take of the scene
and then dutifully did one more the
director requested another but Stallone
politely declined turns out he'd broken
a rib on the second take leading to some
very real cries of anguish Maze Runner
the death cure Dylan O'Brien made a name
for himself with the Maze Runner a
trilogy of sci-fi films based on the
popular series of dystopian young adult
novels the actor happily did his own
stunts for the films but on the third
day of filming the third entry the death
cure a scene involving a car went wrong
O'Brien suffered a concussion a facial
fracture and brain trauma production
shut down for months while he recovered
when O'Brien returned director Wes ball
had a delicate question for him
would it be alright to use some of the
footage from that disastrous day in the
film speaking to USA Today O'Brien
recalled my response was actually like I
need you to it away I would be more
heartbroken than if it just went to
waste
while the injury itself stayed off the
silver screen nobody can deny that
O'Brien turned in some breathtaking
stunt work that day the Wizard of Oz the
Wizard of Oz is full of dazzling moments
and one of the biggest comes shortly
after Dorothy arrives in the merry old
Land of odds specifically Munchkinland
Margaret Hamilton in an unbridled
performance as the Wicked Witch of the
West
was supposed to disappear into thin air
thanks to some obscuring smoke and
pyrotechnics as well as a well-placed
trapdoor
[Music]
but when cameras were rolling the door
didn't work properly
meaning Hamilton literally faced a bunch
of fireworks she endured such severe
burns to her face and hands that she
needed six weeks to recover even then
she had to wear green gloves on her
hands because her skin was still too
tender for makeup at the very least
director Victor Fleming told Hamilton
that they didn't need to reshoot the
Munchkinland exit scene the one that led
to her injuries looked just fine
[Music]